[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROHITASH RAO: So
thanks for coming.
This is crazy, because you're
here at Google, looking at me.
I can't see any of you,
which is probably good.
Before I get into
this particular show,
I just want to give you
a quick little back story
of where this idea comes from.
So years and years ago, I did
this animated short film called
"Battle of the Album Covers."
And the idea behind
this film was
I took pretty much all
of your famous album
covers and had them
all fight each other.
So in the film, Billy Joel
throws the first stone
on his cover of the
album "Glass Houses."
And the rock goes
through the window,
and it hits the mannequins
in Yazoo's album cover
of "Upstairs at Eric's."
And it's just like
a battle ensues.
In fact, you know what?
Why don't we play
that film first,
so you can kind of get a taste
of why I love albums so much.
So let's watch this film,
and then I'll come back.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[FILM REEL TICKING]
- I'm out of here.
- Dude, get me out of here.
- Hey, daddy.
There's somebody stuck in there.
- That's OK, honey.
It's just Sean Cassidy.
- What you got
against Sean Cassidy?
- What you got against this?
[GUNFIRE AND CAR ALARMS]
- Ooh.
- Oh.
- Oh, man.
- Can I get a cheeseburger?
Oh.
[YELLING]
[SCREAMING]
[MOANING]
[CHUCKLING]
- Oh.
[LASER NOISES]
[GUNFIRE]
- 10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5--
[BEEPING]
[EXPLOSION]
- Yeah!
[ROCK GUITAR SOLO]
[SCREAMING]
[GRUNTING]
[DOG GROWLING]
[GARGLING WATER]
- Oh, help me.
[SCREAMING] Oh, God!
- What the hell was that?
- Nothing, baby.
- Hey, what's that up there?
[SCREAMING]
(WHISPERING) Come on, let's go.
- Jump, jump!
Throw the baby!
[SPLASH]
- Hey, man.
Leave that baby alone!
[MOANING]
- Hey, what are you doing?
- Oh, uh, nothing.
- What are you looking at?
- Nothing!
[EXPLOSIONS]
- Let's get the
hell out of here.
- Hurry!
- Run!
[SCREAMING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
ROHITASH RAO: All
right, so that was--
[CHEERING]
Liked it?
So basically, I did
that about 10 years ago.
And the majority of those
albums are actually my albums.
And it was an idea I had since
I was 16, when I was lying
my albums on my bedroom floor.
And I'm like, you know what?
That album could
fight with that album.
And that guy would
fight that guy.
And suddenly, it
just became an idea.
In fact, can we go to
the slides, real quick?
I'm going to show you
a picture of my bedroom
when I was 16 years old.
That's how it looked.
It was very empty.
So this was my
room when I was 16.
For me, when I discovered
music, I really
discovered all the things
that came with music,
like the albums, the posters,
the stickers, the flyers--
I was obsessed.
And I always say that, for me,
record stores were my first art
galleries.
Because it's all the things
I loved in one place.
And I thought it was
just so inspiring.
I'm sure you guys
remember these stores
when you were growing up?
Or some of them
are still around.
But these were my--
it felt like home every
time I was in this place.
So this is where I grew
up-- in Rancho Cucamonga.
I've got one high
school friend here?
Two high school friends here?
AUDIENCE: Best pilot ever.
ROHITASH RAO: Best-- oh, yeah.
I'll get to that.
But basically, this
was my childhood.
And I think that what I
liked about where we grew up
was that there was so much
time with nothing to do.
And I think that a lot of--
the music really seemed
to fill that world.
Everything seemed to
have a soundtrack where
we were growing up.
And before I go any
further, I just wanted to--
one of the best things
growing up when I was a kid
was this show called "Dr.
Demento," which was on KROCK.
And "Dr. Demento" turned
me on to such great artists
as Weird Al Yankovic.
And there was another
great artist back then that
was called Barnes and Barnes.
I don't know if you
ever heard of them.
They did this really
cool video for this song
called "Fish Heads."
Have you ever heard--
you guys know this song?
If you don't know it,
you could look it up.
And for me, this was
like the two things
I loved the most in the
world-- music and comedy.
And I thought there's
something here.
And I loved that these
artists were already doing it.
So I want to give a shout
out to some of the best band
names I've ever heard of--
Scritti Politti, Blancmange,
Sigue Sigue Sputnik,
Poi Dog Pondering--
I mean, Poi Dog Pondering--
where does that come from?
Oingo Boingo, which is also
one of the coolest album
covers, I would say.
And my favorite, I Love You
But I've Chosen Darkness.
That's a real band.
I don't know.
I've seen them in concert
just so I could buy the shirt.
So I started making
my own album covers.
I'm like, you know what?
This is everything I want to do.
So these are just some of the
album covers I started making.
And suddenly, every
single photograph
I took, every
single illustration
I did, every single doodle I
sketched became an album cover.
And now, nothing is sacred.
I will make an album
cover with anything.
And suddenly, everywhere I
go, and everything I read,
and every text I seem to get
seems to be a band title.
It seems to be the
coolest name for a band.
And now, everything I
do is about just this.
I probably make an
album at every meal,
now, just because
I can't help it.
Now, for the best part--
the music.
Jared-- I met Jared
about 10 years ago.
Maybe six years ago.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's been a while.
ROHITASH RAO: It's been a while.
Because this is how I met Jared.
I met Jared because I did
an animated TV pilot for Fox
that Jared and
JinglePunk scored.
It was called, funny
enough, "Rancho Cucamonga,"
which goes back to
exactly where I come from.
So the pilot was basically
about an Indian family
growing up in Cucamonga.
And Jared happened to
be the brilliant guy who
brought the music to life.
So I said to Jared, listen,
I have this crazy idea called
Rohit Records.
And I need musicians.
And you're awesome
and funny and cool.
Why don't you do some music?
And Jared goes,
we actually happen
to have a bunch of
music lying around.
Why don't we just work on it?
And then, we started
talking about it.
And that became what's going to
be the "Rohit Records Greatest
Hits: Volume 1" LP,
which is coming out.
Actually, it's done today.
Today was the day the
press was finished.
So it actually will be
released in about a week.
And we're selling this album.
If you want to pre-buy this
album, talk to me or Jared.
We'll figure it out.
But this is what
this has become.
Now, we have music to go along
with those crazy album covers.
So tonight you're going to
see six one-hit-wonder bands
of Rohit Records.
[CHEERING]
They are going to
rock your socks off
as only the Rohit Records
label musicians can.
[LAUGHTER]
Don't you like that I wrote
all this down somewhere,
and I didn't even
read any of it.
I didn't even need this.
This doesn't even matter.
AUDIENCE: We love you, Ro.
ROHITASH RAO: Oh, you're
awesome, whoever said that.
I can't see anything.
I just see the time, which
says I should get off.
Are you going to come
on now, or are you
going to come on in a minute?
DEL BOCA VISTA: We're ready.
ROHITASH RAO: Should
I announce the band?
[CHEERING]
[LAUGHTER]
ROHITASH RAO: All right,
I'll just leave this up here.
This is the first song
of the first band that's
going to come up tonight.
And I made an album cover
for each of these bands.
So this is the album cover for
the first band, called Del Boca
Vista.
And they're going
to kick it off.
So as they play, I'm
going to show you
the rest of the album covers.
Thanks for coming.
I appreciate your time.
Thanks for coming all the way
to Venice on a Friday night.
I hope you have a good time.
[APPLAUSE]